joining me now is kellyanne conway
former senior counselor to president
trump and author of here's the deal also
dinesh d'souza conservative commentator
host of the dinesh d'souza podcast
kellyanne
um
biden once again following in the great
tradition of his old boss
openly trashing america on the world
stage with his depiction of course and
hearkening back to charlottesville and
making his you know points
about january 6. your reaction tonight
reaction is we're neither feared nor
respected around the globe including at
nato in front of our allies this is the
time to reassure our allies and allay
the fears of many americans laura and
dinesh who are feeling the pain of the
pump feeling the pain in the grocery
store and feeling the pain when we see
they see the vice president two times go
to europe followed by her boss the
president go to europe and engage in
what can only fairly be seen as america
last policy here and abroad uh it's one
thing to castigate and denigrate
americans here at home to make us less
dependent on our own
resources for energy independence it's
quite another to go and do that in front
of a probably a salivating few countries
at nato happy to see a united states
president who's not going to put america
first and says as much and not only is
putin watching and iran and
china and the re the rest of the world
but our military our active military our
veterans our military spouses also hear
an american president say and do that if
you look back to the 2020 presidential
debates foreign policy questions were
conspicuous by their absence
particularly in one of those debates
people were afraid to bring raise it
frankly so we didn't hear enough right
from this man who had been in washington
dc for for 50 years but uh
two quick polling numbers as well to
build on what you said number one in the
ap nrc poll 56 said they think that
biden has not been strong enough in his
response on ukraine that includes 43
percent of democrats 68 of republicans
64 percent of independents only 6
percent of americans say he's been too
strong and finally 74 of americans say
they don't have faith they have a low
level of confidence for biden to handle
a crisis that means a crisis of any type
so you see in there i have i have
something i'm going to make a serious
point it's not a partisan point it's a
serious point i would prefer that joe
biden and kamala harris not go to these
go to these forums anymore i think it's
yeah i want to get to that and yeah yeah
that's just no no i got to get janet on
this kellyanne i got to get i got to get
dinesh in on this dish
to see biden go to europe is to see
american weakness on display
how debilitating is that
to america's you know respect and
prestige around the world and it
certainly doesn't help them at home so i
don't know why they keep sending them
well they don't really have much of a
choice and the europeans are in a very
odd situation in some ways there's a
part of them that wants and yearns for
and demands american leadership and so
that part of them is disappointed in
having this stumbling mumbling figure
who is supposedly the leader of the free
world and is actually embarrassing the
free world in front of the world now
here in america the embarrassment of
biden is somewhat camouflaged by the
thick fog of rhetoric put out by the
media which in a sense is constantly
cloaking and supporting biden but you
don't have that in the rest of the world
they just see a kind of naked biden who
absolutely seems intellectually
incoherent
seems to have no sense of what the
interests of other countries are keeps
making absurd statements like oh there's
a division between the democracies and
the autocracies of the world think of
the largest democracy in the world india
now here's india that buys a lot of
russian oil it's a developing country
that needs that oil in order to grow
economically india doesn't really care
about the ukraine and so india says
we're going to keep buying the oil so
here's a democracy bigger than the
united states in terms of population
that's not on our side on this you think
biden would need to address something
like this but he doesn't he just
pretends like india doesn't exist all
the democracies in the world so you just
have this sing-song routine while the
world looks on in disbelief and
contempt well kellyanne there was
progress today though we have to admit
this because biden
acknowledged that his sanctions are
causing hardship right
with regard to food shortage yes we did
we
talked about food shortages
and uh and it's going to be real
the price of these sanctions is not just
imposed upon russia it's imposed upon an
awful lot of countries as well including
european countries and our country as
well
kellyanne we thought carter's malaise
speech was bad this is a heck of a
midterm message it's going to cost you
150 bucks to fill up your tank and we're
going to get 100 000 refugees billions
out the door and food shortages vote
vote democrat 2022 what a nightmare
message there's nothing like it there's
nothing like that's right there's
nothing uninspiring uh
commander-in-chief to go abroad and
deliver that message also speaking of
sanctions he seems to be the only guy in
his administration in his inner circle
who says that they don't work that they
were never meant to deter his secretary
of state his national security adviser
as vice president and today basically
his press secretary
said that they are meant to deter they
do have a deterrent effect but he says
look man
you know don't joke around with me i
always said that they won't deter so
even on the simplest meaning of the
purpose of sanctions he cannot agree
with his inner circle but
projecting to us back at home
that food is going to continue to be
expensive and then in short supply is
really not the bomb we needed i think
the next time he feels like going abroad
and embarrassing us he should take his
first trip his first trip in quite a
while if ever to the southern border
certainly his first trip as president
dinesh uh
think about what that message says to i
try to think of like middle class family
kind of family i grew up in
as kellyanne said here's that message
today from a from a sitting u.s
president they already feel the gas pump
pain
now they're being told there might not
be food i just want to drive this point
home to the american public
i have never
heard
a a u.s president
speak in these in these terms ever
ever it's going to it's going to it's
going to drive people to the store to
stock up and hoard food at this point i
wouldn't be surprised
i mean i think that if one is going to
make the case that a president who is
supposed to act on behalf of and in the
interests of the american people is
going to take steps that impose this
kind of hardship in ordinary life i mean
think about a guy who makes 15 an hour
and it costs him a hundred dollars and
to fill up your suv that's one day
salary out of five going just to fill up
your tank and biden is doing that to you
and now you think that he'd say well
this is why it is in our vital national
interests that we do this this isn't
just in ukraine's interest it isn't
vital for america that we intervene here
it's vital for america but there's not
even any attempt to show that to to make
that case there's just this kind of
blind rhetoric oh putin is like hitler
and so on and people are just supposed
to salute and go along but i think the
ordinary american is wondering what is
it that justifies this high degree of
sacrifice that our leaders who by the
way don't face the pain themselves are
imposing on the rest of us
yeah i guess a horrible rotten racist
country that his party thinks we are i
mean they're just going to have to
suffer and suffer and suffer for all
their foreign policy mistakes kellyanne
i have to get to this moment from biden
when he
tried to tell the world that he was
really firm with china when it came to
ukraine watch
i had a a very straightforward
conversation with with she i made no
threats but i made it clear to him
that make sure he understood the
consequences of him helping russia china
understands that
its economic future is much more closely
tied
to the west
than it is to russia
and so i i i'm hopeful
that he uh
he does not get engaged
kellyanne oh shouldn't we see the
transcript who buys this
well we should see the full transcript
in fact china put out their version
laura within 20 minutes where you have
to see the full transcript uh i'm sure
president xi is really is convinced and
i'm sure president putin is look china
has already benefited from the biden
presidency he won't hold them to account
on fentanyl which is the number one
killer of 18 to 44 year olds in this
country right now as we sit here he
doesn't hold him account for their
persecution of the uyghurs he doesn't
hold them to account for the virus he
doesn't hold them to account for the 85
billion dollars of american equipment
and intelligence that is with in china's
wingspan that biden left behind when he
allowed the taliban to take kabul and
the 13 service members to perish not
listening to his quote generals so i i
don't believe biden when he says he'll
stick it to china um he knows that
hunter biden's done very well there he's
not going to take on
president xi and if we don't believe if
the polls here in this country
don't show credibility and competence
vis-a-vis our own president you can't
expect the rest of the world
particularly someone like president xi
to feel that way
yeah she and putin or at least she is
laughing and that's sad for america
kellyanne dinesh thank you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else